[Applause]
[Music]
I am sure that now after the Russian
disaster that we have all witnessed you
probably think that Moscow has thrown
all of its military muscle into Ukraine
and yes in a way it has Russia has
already deployed its main fighting
forces in Ukraine which for example has
led them to lose more than 2 000 tanks
representing more than half of other
operational tank reserves and this is
just one example however despite this at
the same time we also come across news
stories like this one US blames Russia's
Wagoner group for worsening security in
Mali and of course I'm sure you're
wondering what on Earth is happening
here what interest does Russia have in
Mali I mean Russia is here and Mali is
here I don't know at first glance it
doesn't seem to make much sense what do
the Russians care about what happens in
Africa if you're a long time follower of
us here at visualpolitik you already
know that Russia has tentacles all
around the world but why are they in
Africa right now think about it until
2022 Russia had a very clear area of
influence in Central Asia and the
Caucasus however one year later all of
that power is fading away Kazakhstan is
moving further and further away from the
Russian sphere and what about the
conflict between Army and Azerbaijan we
are talking of course about the
nagorno-karabakh dispute for decades
Russia has played the role of arbiter in
this dispute but now it is not present
nor is it expected to be what's more
many countries that were once in
moscow's orbit are increasingly looking
to Beijing however Africa remains on the
kremlin's agenda and more specifically
on the agenda of the Wagner group
you already know that the Wagner group
is a private company basically a private
Army a Putin's service its owner yevgeni
preguzin is a close friend of the
president we are talking about a company
that is having no problem throwing its
men into Ukraine even if it is meant
throwing them headlong into a terrible
slaughterhouse but they aren't only in
Ukraine they also have enough muscle for
Africa and the question is why and to
what extent do African countries oppose
this Russian influence well the truth is
that unfortunately many of these
countries are so poor that they couldn't
afford to repel invading forces not even
Wagner however this is the most
important question we can ask ourselves
is Russia the only Power with a presence
in Africa evidently not there is another
European country that has never
abandoned its Imperial dreams which
country are we talking about exactly
France the visualpolitic faithful will
already know that France never fully
gave up its former colonies and you will
also know that French colonialism was
anything but kind we have even talked
previously about the competition between
France and China for influence in Africa
however the truth is that the arrival of
Russia has turned everything upside down
of course you may ask but really I how
much influence can a group of Russian
mercenaries like the Wagner's have well
it is certainly not a trifling matter
look at this map
although the Russian presence is not the
only reason why France still retain
significant troops in Africa the fact is
that lately this reason has become
increasingly important to give you an
idea the trips that France deployed in
the sahil in 2013. today now total more
than 3 000 troops and before the
withdrawal from Mali at the end of last
year they numbered as many as
5100. Russia already has 3 000
mercenaries in Africa it is clear that
there are fewer Russians than French but
they are comparable figures of course we
also have to rely on International
forces such as the U.N blue helmets but
let's be clear the UN is not exactly a
Panacea when it comes to influence be
that as it may one thing is indisputable
in terms of political influence France
Remains the largest foreign power in the
region and certainly its presence is
much greater than that of Russia it has
more military bases more contacts in the
area and a stronger economic tie however
where France used to be practically the
only sheriff in the area it's no
contested by two Powers China and Russia
we have already discussed China's
presence in Africa at length here on
visual politics but in today's video
we're going to focus on Russia so the
question then becomes to what extent is
French dominance in Africa crumbling
what can France do to remain strong in
the region why might its presence be so
important what interest does Russia have
and what bearing does all this have for
the war in Ukraine today we're going to
answer all of these questions but first
let's look at some history
foreign
[Music]
on visual politic we have always been
against colonialism and surely today no
one is going to start saying let's
colonize India again long live the
colonies
don't look at Britain too closely well
maybe there are some but it certainly
won't be us however we should not forget
that not all cases of colonialism have
been the same there have been colonial
empires that left some government
structures in place and when they left
either voluntarily or because they were
thrown out they did so completely this
was for example the case of Spain with
America however our protagonist in this
video friends did the opposite
[Music]
France arrived late to the first wave of
colonization you know that of the
American continent in spite of this it
managed to take over a good chunk of
North America and later significant
territories in Southeast Asia however it
is not that period of the French Empire
that we usually remember as the most
prosperous in terms of domains but
rather that of the 19th century while
Spain was going through a deep crisis
losing its last American colonies and
the Philippines in 1898. France was
booming following the Berlin Conference
of 1885. it managed to position itself
along with the United Kingdom as the
largest Colonial Empire in Africa while
it is true that their first settlements
on the continent date back to the
mid-17th century in Senegal and they had
already taken control of territories
such as the Ivory Coast Gabon and
Algeria between 1840 and 1850. it was
not until 1885 that the French Empire
reached its peak suddenly their
dominance in Africa was giving the
British a run for their money and you
know what France went all out to make
the most of these calls France was
dedicated to exploring as many mineral
resources as possible
foreign
not surprisingly building institutions
and infrastructure was not at the top of
their list to be honest they were there
to exploit their resources period they
had no interest in developing their
colonies beyond what was necessary for
the extractive Machinery to operate at
full capacity in fact French colonial
rule is especially remembered for being
among the harshest as demonstrated for
example by the massacres in the Algerian
cities of satif and guelma although if
you want a truly brutal Empire wait
until you hear about the Belgian
atrocities in the Congo it's a topic
that we've already covered in a past
video here on visualpolitik however
everything began to change after World
War II the United States and the Soviet
Union however much they differed reached
an agreement on common point the
colonies had to go so nosuno said than
done the UN created the special
committee on decolonization and the
colonial empires began to be dismantled
in this process the United Kingdom Left
Behind Nigeria and all of its African
colonies Spain did the same with
Equatorial Guinea and its occupation of
Morocco but what about France well the
reality visual politic viewers is that
France had a hard time letting go of the
reins of these territories and in fact
even today we can still see remnants of
what was its former Empire you see
before the French colonies became
independent de Gaulle got the new
countries to accept that monetary policy
would be controlled by France itself and
so the CFA Franc was born
[Music]
this is the legal tender in 14 countries
previously pegged to the Frank and now
pegged to the euro and where are the
largest currency reserves of the CFA
Franc held exactly in France in other
words France maintains enormous control
over these economies if that is not a
hangover from colonialism I don't know
what is and I know what many of you are
thinking well I mean that's not so bad
having a currency pegged to the euro
means that these countries have managed
to avoid hyperinflation and yes you are
right but Francis control is not only
limited to the economy
France is also well known for supporting
authoritarian governments and why you
may ask the answer lies in one word
mineral resources okay two words
basically Fran supports authoritarian
governments in exchange for France being
given preference and extracting natural
resources where do you think all the
uranium for the famous French nuclear
power plants comes from or mainly from
Niger a former French colony where the
orano company has almost full control of
the mains so when there have been
protests against these Authority
governments France has not hesitated to
send its troops to control the situation
and they did so from the very first
moment as happened in the 1964 coup
d'etat in Gabon a coup that took place
only four years after the country won
its independence from France in other
words don't worry Gabon you are now free
as long as you do exactly what I tell
you to do this is just one example but
in general it has been the usual
behavior of a country that has tended to
roam freely in its former colonies even
after they became independent however at
the beginning of the new century a new
player began to steal France's Thunder
check this out
[Music]
the new Chinese friend
foreign
to no one's surprise China the Asian
giant has become a key player in Africa
it is nothing unusual Africa has the
resources that China needs and China has
the economic capacity to enable African
countries to develop or at least for
them to be able to carry out major
infrastructure projects what's more
African markets have not yet fully
blossomed so China has the opportunity
to get there when that happens to get
its share of the pie and take advantage
for example of cheap labor so both
public and private companies in China
began to take an interest in investing
in African countries although it must be
said there are precedents from the 1960s
with the first railroad line in Zambia
through to the Addis adabat devotee
connections completed in 2016 China had
built more than 6 000 kilometers that's
over 3 700 miles of railroads in Africa
by 2022 and not only that it is also
invested in the construction of
industrial parks such as the one in
Addis Ababa hospitals roads and much
more take a look analysts China
expanding influence in Africa via
Telecom Network deals do you see the
difference China doesn't just extract
natural resources apparently it also
gives a lot of things in return
[Music]
China has helped African countries to be
connected to the world not to be
isolated and instead to receive
real-time information not only by
investing in telecommunications
infrastructure but also by producing
affordable cell phones for their markets
naturally this also translates into
political influence they have opened
dozens of Confucius institutes where
Chinese is taught in addition they
provide television broadcasting which
means that millions of Africans watch
Pro Xi Jinping TV programs and one thing
is clear China has offered Africa what
France never did the chance to negotiate
as equals or at least not to be treated
as subjects and as you can imagine this
is pretty bad news for France but let's
not fool ourselves either the Chinese
presence does not work miracles Africa
still has many problems and one of the
most important is radicalism but what
are we talking about here pay attention
to this
France in free fall
until now France has maintained its
influence in Africa more or less
discreetly okay yes it supported the
occasional coup d'etat participated in
covert missions back the occasional
authoritarian government but the
right in 2013 there was a turning point
though France re-entered the African
political scene why because War had
broken out in Mali
in 2012 Mali had to start dealing with
the two-hour egg Rebellion organized in
the north of the country by the national
movement for the liberalization of Aswad
this movement which has links to
jihadist groups and Sarah red DIN and
al-Qaeda in the Islamic maghreb began a
harsh Insurgency campaign against the
central government of Mali they
conquered more and more territory and at
the end Mali had no choice but to ask
France for help this is how operation
serval began to which Paris assigned
some 3 000 military personnel the
intervention was initially a success
peace was agreed with the Tuareg in June
2013 and the then president hollon was
able to walk triumphantly through the
streets of bamako the capital of Mali in
addition the UN established a permanent
peacekeeping Mission menusma however
peace was a short-lived thing and in
September hostilities began again in the
country accelerating the spread of
johara's terrorism throughout the region
a wave of terrorism that has hit Mali
Niger and Burkina Faso particularly
harmed
thank you
the situation got so out of hand that
France had to send more troops operation
Sarah Val gave way to operation bar Kane
which ended in November last year
Brands needed to protect its resource
extracting companies such as niger's
uranium and Miley's oil in other words
the French focused solely on fighting
jihadism in areas where natural
resources were present problems soon
arose the most important of these was
probably the training of local armies at
first glance this didn't seem to be
anything wrong with that in fact it's
even what you might expect well guess
what it turns out that it has become one
of the biggest problems just take a look
at this graph as you can see in 2020 in
both Burkina Faso and Mali there were
more civilian deaths at the hand of
National Security forces and by the
jihadists themselves and that is
actually not unusual think about it
ethnic conflicts are quite common in
this part of the world normally the
armies of each of these countries are
dominated by one particular ethnic group
suddenly France started to train and arm
armies which in turn were dominated by
one particular ethnic group these ethnic
groups used and still use all this
French aid to Massacre the other ethnic
groups do you need an example Burkina
Faso
the Army is dominated by the mossy
ethnic group which did not hesitate for
a second to kill people of the Fulani
and pure ethnic group and what is the
outcome when this happens the most
predictable one that those under attack
look for someone to protect them like
the jihadists and this is how we enter a
vicious circle where French aid
translates into more violence and more
jihadism do you understand why France
does not have such a good image in these
countries now explains why in August of
2022 Mali said look France thank you
very much for your help but how about
you leave us alone and we will manage on
our own as you can imagine the other
neighboring countries are going in the
same direction check this out burkino
Faso unrest France agrees to pull its
troops out a time when France's image
seems to be at rock bottom and
confidence in this nation is an all-time
low the question is who will step in to
fill the void left by France I know what
you were all thinking at the moment
China right the Chinese friend who
treats Africans as equals provides them
with infrastructure and
Telecommunications networks and even
helps them to industrialize right well
no nothing actually could be further
from the truth here's the moment when it
comes time four
[Music]
the Russian bear hug
look at it it's this one do you see
anything that catches your eye that's
right what you're looking at crossed
with the hoe is an AK-47 the most famous
Soviet assault rifle in history to be
fair although it is something out of the
ordinary it makes all the sense in the
world after all this was the most
popular weapon during their independence
process and in these processes the
Soviet Union and its allies played an
important role in the cases of several
countries when we see news such as the
withdrawal of French troops from Burkina
Faso it is not difficult to imagine that
Russia could come to replace France in
the region
in fact as we already mentioned at the
beginning of this video Russia has
already set to work through the
mercenary group Wagner it started in
Libya and Sudan in 2017 and today it has
reached to Mozambique Mali and the
Central African Republic but you might
be wondering what is the importance of
this isn't it just another private
company well yes it is just another
company providing a somewhat unusual
service but there is something else
behind this company also take a look at
this From Russia with Love A Putin Ally
mines gold and plays favorites in Sudan
backed by the Kremlin the shadowy
network known as the Wagner group is
getting rich in Sudan while helping the
military to crush a democracy movement
exactly visual politic viewers the
Wagner group is helping Putin to extract
gold and not only in Sudan in Mali they
have exploitation rates over three other
gold mines and as many others in the
Central African Republic as well however
their main target has always been
Burkina Faso why
because they extracts 70 tons of gold
annually making it one of the largest
producers in Africa in other words every
year Burkina Faso extracts as much gold
as Denmark has and its gold reserves and
not surprisingly Putin is rubbing his
hands together with news like this clock
in a group allegedly given bakino Faso
mine in exchange for help fighting
Jihadi extremists as you can imagine it
suits Putin justifying that the Wagner
group is extracting gold from Africa in
order to finance his war in Ukraine but
this would not have been possible
without the failure of France's fight
against terrorism in the region and the
widespread discontent that Paris has
created but do you think this discontent
was caused by France alone hasn't it had
something to do with Russia well in part
yes France has done disastrously badly
that is true but Russia knew how to play
its cards very well what card are we
talking about
history Kremlin propaganda has taken
care to remained Africans who was on
their side when they gained independence
from their colonial Masters and in the
end this message has taken hold and have
been part of the responsibility of the
Wagner group itself which is also in
charge of marketing campaigns in favor
of Russia in all of these countries in
fact since the end of 2019 Facebook has
had to close more than 300 accounts
associated with Wagner's boss who was
spreading Russian propaganda in more
than 12 African countries so while it is
clear that while China is devouring
France's economic ground Russia is
basically pushing aside in security
matters so the question is is France
giving up is that it let's find out
[Music]
a necessary change of course
by now it's clear that France's image in
much of Africa is destroyed admittedly
there have been times when it was
unfairly criticized such as when it
withdrew its troops from Mali altogether
amid multiple accusations of abandoning
the fight against terrorism even though
it had been Mali itself that had driven
the French out but truth be told macron
knows the role France has played in
Africa over the past decades has often
been reprehensible that is precisely why
he is now redefining his strategy
macron government has already set to
work in Africa and has begun negotiating
new agreements with countries in the
region in fact it is already committed
from the beginning of 2022 to invest in
the construction of infrastructure like
China does in other words Franzen tends
to start doing now what other countries
have already done with their colonies in
the past
France joins China in infrastructure
projects what's more in view of the
failure of the anti-terrorist operation
in the sahil France wants to avoid at
all costs such a prolonged military stay
in the future for this reason it is
offered to promote the construction of
military academies in the coast and
Deputy among other countries not only
that France has also offered logistical
intelligence and combat support in
specific situations
macron seems to have understood that the
strategy being pursued by his
predecessors was not working France's
image was being tarnished more than
necessary in Africa
[Music]
in a way the new measure he is proposing
are very close to the Classic Soft power
we have already talked about here on
visualpolitik in other words less stick
and much more carrot however they may
prove to be insufficient in the face of
a Chinese partner that has shown African
countries a more ambitious path and
Russia apparently more capable of
fighting terrorism if only to get their
hands on gold and diamond mines of
course but the Russians know very well
how to get along with sat traps and even
better than the French the fact is that
France will have to adapt to a
multi-polar Africa in which it will no
longer be the clearly dominant power but
now the questions are over to you to
what extent is France willing to change
its treatment of Africa after 200 years
will it be able to maintain its
influence how can Russia fill the gaps
left by the French army you can leave me
your answers in the comments below and
as always don't forget that here on
visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to us all here
at this Channel and hit the little bell
button down there so you don't miss any
of our updates if you like this video
like it so we know all the best and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
foreign